معنا الان المحلل السياسي والساده في
الاكاديميه الروسيه من موسكو محمود
الافندي اهلا بكم استاذ محمود بدايه من
الانطباع السائد الان داخل روسيا وسندا
ايضا الى هذا التصريح للافروف هل كان
بمثابه الضغط على مشاورات اليوم في جنيف
ام اعلان مسبق بعدم اعطاء الضوء الاخضر من
قبل التمديد
الكريم والاخوه المشاهدين طبعا روسيا يعني
حسب من حوالي اربعه اشهر وحتى الان او ست
اشهر على كلام الرئيس بوتين تقول ان هي
اتفاقيه تطبق فقط بعض البنود يعني يطبق
فقط البنوك مع التحفظ الروسي على هذه
البيوت تطبق يعني المفروض ان الحبوب تذهب
الى دول فقيره اغلبيتها حاولت تذهب الى
دول غنيه وهذا ما يسمى يعارض المبدا
الانساني ان هذا الحبوب ستذهب الى الدول
حتى تقف المجاعه او نقص الحبوب في دول
العالم الفقيره هذا اول شيء بالاتفاقيه لن
تطبق اوكرانيا ما يسمى
فتح انبوب الاسمده الامياك بنت مدينه
الولايات الروسيه حتى اوديسا هذا موجود في
الاتفاقيه حتى الان الجهه الاوكرانيه لم
تطبقه بالاضافه الى الدول الغربيه التي
تفرض العقوبات حتى الان لم ترفع العقوبات
عن ما يسمى السير المواد الغذائيه والحبوب
الى دول العالم الاخر هذا كان ضمن اتفاقيه
روسيا روسيا الان تقول في يعني بس ثواني
بس روسيا تقول اتفاقيه كامله
اما ان تاخذها كلها او لن اخش شي منها
يعني السؤال يطرح هنا استاذ محمود يعني
هذا ليس اول تمديد لماذا تثير هذه الاسمده
الروسيه وتحديدا مساله الامونيا التي اشرت
الى هذا الانبوب لنقلها عبر هذا الميناء
في اوكرانيا لماذا تثير كل هذا
التعقيدات وقد تهدد بعدم تمديد الاتفاقيه
280 من الاسمده موجود روسيا لافريقيا ضمن
الاتفاقيه نخرج منها غير 20 طن فقط بناء
البحر البطيخ يعني فعليا والاميال احد
الاسباب لانه نعلم جيدا ان الدول فقيره
تعتمد بشكل كبير على الاسمده بسبب فقر
التربه ففعليا عدم اعطاء هذه الاسئله
للدول الفقيره سيؤدي مماثي ومهمه الامم
المتحده هي ان تنهي الماساه ومسمى خطر
الفقر على هذه الدول فالروسيا لا تعلم
يعني كيف ستفهم الامم المتحده ان هذه
الاتفاق انساني او اقتصادي يعني نرى لترى
روسيا فعليه الان ان هذه تصدر الى الدول
الغنيه الى الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي مقابل
ان يعطيها سلاح يعني احد ما يسمى نوع من
انواع الدفع عن طريق الحبوب فهذا يعني
ايضا ضد روسيا يعني دائما تكون الحروب
دائما الحرب الاقتصاديه اهم انواع السلاح
فمن روسيا مصلحتها ان تضرب الاقتصاد
الاوكراني فالان ابوك اذا كان الانطباع
السائد هو ما لم نفهمه من كلامك سيد محمود
يعني انه طلب اوكرانيا مؤخرا او قبل ايام
بتمديد او تجديد الاتفاقيه لتشمل مجال
الصلب الاوكراني سيكون طلبا مرفوضا بالطبع
من قبل روسيا
طبعا انا اقول كل اتفاقيه انا باعتقادي
انه راح يكون هناك ضمانات الامم المتحده
على تطبيق الاتفاقيه كامله يعني فعليا
يمكن ان يطبق بعض البنود الاخرى يعني يمكن
ان يحصل نوع من انواع من انواع الضغط على
تطبيق الاتفاقيه من طرف الامم المتحده هي
المسؤوله عن هذه الاتفاقيه وليست دول
الغربيه فيجب على ان يضغط على دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لتطبيق ورفع العقوبات على المواد
الغذائيه الروسيه ففعليا انا باعتقادي انا
الان هناك مباحثات جديه ويمكن فعليا ان
نرى يمكن للطرف الغربي او الطرف الاوكراني
ان يطبق كل الاتفاقيه فعليا فعليا يعني
هذه الاتفاقيه اصبحت يعني نوعا ما نوع من
انواع التواصل الدبلوماسي بين روسيا
والغرب هذا امر مهم جدا فليس مصلحه الغرب
ان تخرج موسى الاتفاقيه الوقت ليس مصلحه
روسيا ان تخرج خارج الاتفاقيه الذهب ان من
تقوم الجوع وتقسم الانسانيه في افريقيا
فانا براي فعليا سيصحى هناك نوعا ما نوع
من انواع الضمانات لتطبيق كل الاتفاقيه
هذا امر شكرا جزيلا لك محمود الافندي
المحلل السياسي والاستاذ في الاكاديميه
الروسيه كنت معنا من موس